the Joe Rogan experience excellent
actually you are working with me tonight
yeah two sold-out shows at the Hollywood
improv
I appreciate it I'm excited there it's
gonna be fun it's gonna be the Machine
Bert Kreischer love Bert and cheeto
Santino Andrew Santino you know Andrew I
know I know and I don't know if I don't
know him personally just no one knows me
solaris yeah yeah should be a good old
[ __ ] time yeah thanks for having my
pleasure my plate how long you in town
for I leave tomorrow morning right here
on Sunday I got here Saturday actually
and I stayed down Manhattan Beach what
are you doing hanging out with the
people by the beach there was night was
down the airport my wife is here and I
said let's go down in Manhattan Beach
for lunch and we were enjoying ourselves
so we got a hotel and made love and
walked on the way went to a party once
in Manhattan Beach and the guy collected
toasters huh and I was like what is this
and he was like oh I just collect
toasters I'm like okay from all
different time periods like he had a
luncheon toaster from like the 50's with
all this patina on it and then he had
modern toasters but he I think he was
trying too hard
you know though some dudes just wear
bowling shoes and [ __ ] they just try too
hard to be whacking yeah it was he like
a hipster was an old girl he was a guy
who's trying to [ __ ] my girlfriend oh
and she wanted to go to this party all
right
Wow I think she was an actress and I
think he was in the movie business
magic getting cooked by a toaster
collector yeah almost did well it wasn't
it was one of them squirrely deals where
she was like say I'm so not interested
in him I just want to go this party for
Network thing I was a young lad I had
just moved to Hollywood it did not know
the ways of this goofy [ __ ] town yet
yeah I hadn't I hadn't exercised myself
from Hollywood input you know I was
still doing the thing acting going on
auditions and [ __ ] mm-hmm so it was like
you when you first get here you're like
what is this especially in the 90s it
was super squirrely because everybody
was trying to get a development deal and
everybody was trying to get a sitcom and
they kind of like let you think that
that was the only way right you have to
get a sitcom I want to be like Roseanne
I just want to be like Tim Allen
what about Seinfeld he got a sitcom you
should get a sitcom damn I want to get a
sitcom and so everybody was out here
just trying to do the acting thing I did
it for a while and after a while like
these people are not worth it
but you did get a sitcom right yeah yeah
yeah I got a couple of them and I was on
a couple of them it seems like fun it's
fun stand-ups more fun yeah it's not
something I'd be interested in doing but
if you could do a sitcom with all
stand-ups that would be the [ __ ] that
would be the [ __ ] like if you if you
could do a sitcom with really good
writers who are cool and all the people
on the show were stand-ups that would be
[ __ ] monstrous yeah it's not usually
like that no and it seems very uh what
do you call it corporate and you got to
do this in this and a lot of rules and
stuff it seems like podcaster well
they're trying to make money you know
and they can't make money if people do
things and get people in trouble they
say things get people angry or someone
calls up human resources and Joe list
was talking about his dick yeah the
craft service lady heard it and now
there's a lawsuit I think with podcasts
now most of us comedians with podcasts
have no chance of getting any corporate
job I don't think that's true really I
could offer [ __ ] all the time I think
that we don't need it though right I
think it's it actually will get in the
way have you ever written on a sitcom no
written on anything when you write it
there's a trap that comics falling into
that are good writers they get this
sitcom writing gig and it's a sweet gig
you get paid thousands of dollars a week
you build your bills are covered so you
feel good right but you're never going
on the road you're you're in town all
the time you're just doing sets around
town so you're pretending that you're
still comic right but you're really a
sitcom writer who kind of like has a
hobby yeah doing stand-up and you never
develop on the road and there's a bunch
of guys do you know Owen Smith I that's
another guy I don't know I've met him a
couple walk in hilarious yeah one of the
best comics in the world and he's just
been spending so many years doing these
sitcoms like I saw him one night at the
comic store I'm like how the [ __ ] is
this guy not gigantic like how does he
not have a Netflix hour that everyone's
talking about how is it everybody not
trying to book in places that's just
because he's been doing this this sitcom
writer thing
to break out of that now though Tommy
John against another guy you know Tommy
John again I've heard of him he's one of
the best comedians I think there is he's
a writer but he's been writing on a TV
show but he's happy he likes he's got
two kids and it keeps him off the road
but to me it's a bummer as a comedy
phantom like I want to see our but he's
still I think he still works a little
bit yeah Mitch Hedberg had a really
funny bit about that about how comedy
like when your convenience the only job
or someone asks you to do another job
yeah yeah yeah it was somebody I first
moved to New York there was a guy that
was like do you do any writing and I was
like well I did all that writing I wrote
all that but I that's why I never liked
writing other than stand-up could stand
up I can write all day and then go do it
that night
whereas when I'm writing like a movie or
a TV show I'm wasting my get made which
is not my therapist says that's not the
way that's not what you inspired to
write because it's a way to express
yourself you therapist is right but then
again if you are writing something and
nothing happens how is [ __ ] stupid it
feels it feels wasteful
jokes that I do on stage yeah you you
just get into that sort of thing where
you just like what am I doing here and
then it steals your thunder yeah I feel
that way all the time
unrelated
[Applause]